good morning my name is Nick Hagar I am
the head of Western Europe Middle
Eastern Africa for sandoz international
which is a large pharmaceutical company
the question I'd like to address is the
empowerment of women at the grassroots
level yesterday was privileged to listen
to a presentation from Sudan from South
Sudan where women's university is
actively engaged in sending their
students across all love rural
communities of Sudan to educate third
the women and the communities about
women's rights and a bag women's health
I think this initiative can be explored
can be extended and reach across Africa
so that the young women of today can
become the ambassadors and the champions
of Health in on rural communities I
think will be fantastic and an amazing
step cause